okay this question comes from cyprian
sigonic
among all the uap incidents you've
investigated
which one stands out to you
for me it's the 2004 nimitz tic-tac
incident because we have the most
comprehensive uh multi-spectral data on
it now do we have access to all of that
but we at least have the rational
stories or excuse me anecdotes and and a
certain paper trail to follow that says
that those tapes were taken
and so
the first thing that says to me is in
2004 there was a program running that
was ready to respond to incidences like
this at least to debrief and retrieve
elint data
[Music]
but that's that's all i know but to me
that's the most interesting because we
can nail down the most
uh the most comprehensive pieces of an
investigation something worthwhile
occurred
and that there's more information out
there that we can
that we could get on it we could clarify
if we had that information we would know
a lot more
and it's multi you know i i say
multi-spectral i want to be careful when
i say that i'm saying multi-point
multi-point so to me that's the most
interesting one and granted i was there
i don't think my eyewitness account is
the most interesting thing of it i think
it's way towards the bottom of the list
it's completely unprovable
um
but beyond that that's my one i'd be
interested to hear what it has to say
uh i said before it's like choosing my
favorite kid right um
i love them all i find something
interesting in every single of the
incidents that i've been privy to
some are very very compelling some are a
bit more anecdotal some are
you know as i've said before i i can't
provide more than other than saying
there's there's a 23 minute video that's
really really really compelling
um you know
those are the ones that leave you really
scratching your head saying
what the hell did i just see
um
you know
my hope is that the senate some of these
instances become more and more um
prevalent and and people in in office
particularly congress
are successful in getting some of this
stuff declassified that some of the more
compelling
videos and incidents will become more
public public knowledge and then and
then you can have that conversation
right then i can ask you
the same question what which one is your
most compelling incident right now there
there
there's there's so many of them and
they're some of them were just
truly baffling um
but you know unfortunately there's
there's well most of it i really can't
can't talk about yet in the public
sphere
which for me is very frustrating sure
which one stands out that you can talk
about would it be the nimitz as well
well the nimitz was certainly one of the
most comprehensive investigations that
thing went on for a while there were
several investigations there's a lot of
documentation reporting on it a lot of
it was made public
um i think it's you know it's it's
certainly one of the gold standards for
for the us government as far as
investigations
but there's
[Music]
there's a lot more i mean there
chris will tell you the story about him
seeing an email
from somebody a very senior ranking
person in the navy basically saying i
got these things all over my ship what
do you want me to do
you know i can't keep people below deck
forever i mean
people are going to see these things how
do you want me to to what do you want
about what do you want me to do about
this right because i'm they're they're
it's very prevalent and and this is
going to be this won't be able to be
kept secret for very long so
you know that's an example of of of just
sheer frustration in some cases you're
like you know
we've got to get a handle on this we
really do we gotta we got to figure this
out